for two consecutive days now the daily
death toll has
passed 300 grim figures
last seen back in may there are almost
10 000 patients in uk hospitals
infected with 19 and that figure
is rising the whole of nottinghamshire
will be the latest region to enter into
tier 3 restrictions
the government says breaking the chain
of transmission is the only way to stop
the spread of this deadly disease
i think we've lost the plot now i think
i just don't understand what they're
doing
and i think people have been baffled by
what they're doing as well i don't think
they've been very clear on
exactly what it means i think a lot of
people actually think that
we're going into lockdown again very
confusing
i'm definitely confused 100
literally i have no idea what's going
what's going on
the rise in infections is putting
pressure on the nhs
nottingham university hospitals trust
has already been forced to postpone
four cancer treatments the trust said
it was an extremely difficult decision
prescott has been in tier three for two
weeks
the medical director for saint helens
and nosley nhs
trust told me its hospitals were working
under a great deal of pressure
there's no doubt we're busy and we've
got numbers of inpatients
that are quietly approaching that which
we had in the first wave through
march and april earlier in the year um
and that brings its own particular
challenge because we are keeping
our elective programmes running
alongside all of that
do you think local restrictions are
having the desired effect
we know from the reports of the number
of positive cases in the community
that that's starting to drop are we
feeling that translating into
a different experience here in the
hospital
not yet but i wouldn't expect us to are
you confident you will be able to cope
in the
the days and weeks ahead
i'm going to say yes to you because i
know that
we'll come in every day and do this for
our patients
is it pressured and difficult and
challenging yes of course it is
in england there are over 8 000 patients
in hospital
this compares to 17 172
at the peak in april we know that most
of these patients
are in the northwest some trusts are
seeing more patients now
than they did during the peak in wales
there are 685 patients
compared to 919 back in april
scottish hospitals are treating eleven
hundred covid19 patients
at the peak there were 1520
but northern ireland has surpassed the
peak for the number of patients
it's treating as of two days ago they
had 360 covered 19 patients
and at the peak the highest was 322.
the manchester region another tier three
area
will benefit from some extra hospital
capacity
its local nightingale hospital will
become the first of these specialist
surge capacity hospitals
to accept non-covered patients for
therapy
and social care assessments
at least four hospital trusts across
england have decided
to pause some elective procedures it's a
blow for patients
bus with the predicted 25 000 people in
hospital
by the end of next month more hospitals
may be forced
to do the same ashish joshi sky news